so tell us a little bit about your life
what makes your life interesting carrie
what
pops in your life right now well i have
someone who wants to say hi
i know this is a podcast but my little
boy oh my god is that a
funny rabbit it's a little brown you
know i'm glad you said bunny because i
wasn't sure at first it doesn't
it's not the classic white bunny with
the long ears no
when you tilted it down i didn't know i
thought it could be a ferret
uh no i i didn't know i i didn't know i
didn't know it was a bunny can i uh
wow what's what's your bunny's name her
name's momo
momo okay yeah and she is a fan she
loves your podcast
oh well that's actually the target
audience is uh
rabbits and yeah any rodent actually or
a rabbit
yeah is uh is that's what we were aiming
for so i'm happy
about well tell us about moma uh
she's like my little child i love her um
and
she's honestly like a dog she like
sleeps with me at night
she knows tricks uh what do you mean
what tricks does a rabbit know
she i taught her how to like stand up
and spin
and give her a call wait a minute you
taught her to spin how did you teach her
to spin
she loves she lost a treat so she'll do
it for a treat
so you just put her on a record player
and you thought that that was teaching
her
yes exactly you glued your rabbit to a
an old
authentic record player and then you're
like look at this cool trick
i thought of it wow so momo
is uh is content momo mobile's a happy
bunny
i i like to think so and uh who else is
in the picture
is there a significant other i mean i'm
not trying to pry
i i live alone but my boyfriend
basically lives here
half the week with me really do you like
that he hangs out that much is
you know or is he kind of coming by too
much and eating a lot out of the fridge
he likes to cook so i mean oh nice okay
so he cooks yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
what do we think of this what's this
guy's name his name is august wow that's
a cool name
wow yeah and uh so how'd you meet augie
uh we have like mutual friends so we've
known each other for a while
right were you friends first and then
things started to heat up but kind of
like what sort of what's wrong i don't
know if you're okay
i mean if i'm being inappropriate sona
is not inappropriate
it's not it's just wait we've been
talking to her for three minutes
and now we're we know everything already
well that's what i do
that's the that's what i do i need to
find out about august and his intentions
i care about carrie i want to know if
this is the right guy for her
okay you're right all right i just need
to yeah i mean does he like the bunny
that's my question
yes that's a deal breaker so how quickly
they get along
so if he had said ew a rabbit you would
have kicked august out
oh 100.
what kind of rabbit is it is there are
there different types of rabbit or
rabbit types of rabbits yeah she's
called a holland loft
a holland lock okay all right can you
elaborate on that a little bit uh
they're known to have the floppy ears oh
that's why the ears aren't sticking up
yeah
yeah yeah that's why it didn't look like
a rabbit to me
it looks like oh yeah yeah it looks like
a very small
uh basset hound you know that that went
through the dryer
you know what i mean that's kind of what
it looked like to me well momo needs a
friend too
so maybe i'll get another one and they
met conan or
katakai or something very nice oh
long time listener what if they do it
and they have like a million bunnies
yeah is that is that an issue if you get
another rabbit they could do it
um you fixed like you get them fixed
like a pet someone was fixed so she
can't have
babies tragic mama might have
uh i like you and the rabbit's okay i
don't have i have not bonded yet with
the rabbit i don't
know i don't feel a bond with the rabbit
you know all you did was say look at my
rabbit and then you moved
your uh your camera and i quickly saw
a form that's what i saw i guess
we can't be friends no no i just know
now wait a minute terry mom good mom no
carrie i'm not saying
i i'm not saying i don't there's not a
chance for me to love
momo just sort of like i say this about
my brother neil all the time
i want to love him but we just haven't
had enough time yet
you know it's only been like 58 years
and so we just need more time
you know and and that's how i feel about
momo i just met momo so i'd be lying if
i said oh i can't
i live for momo that would be a lie you
don't want me to lie dude you live for
58 years
but you said he he she she
okay can you hold momo up to us she
doesn't like to be honest
she's not into this at all might have
just been a stuffed bunny
yeah i don't think that was a real
rabbit i honestly don't i swear she's
real
how do we know you didn't even and then
oops oh how convenient can you
can you hold the rabbit up to the camera
oh the rabbit just left the rabbit
had to go see its lawyer it just doesn't
something's mysterious about this rabbit